[Music]
Billy Lauren and Taylor Lautner have
reportedly called it quits after seven
months of dating oh my god but People
magazine reports they're playing it cool
quote they are still friendly she is
really focused on her work right now et
has reached out to both reps for comment
the scream queens co-stars started
dating in December right before the
deaths of Billy's mom Carrie Fisher and
her grandmother Debbie Reynolds Taylor
was by Billy side and even attended
services for both women then it was off
to Mexico for the lovebirds the 25 year
old actor instagrammed this photo of his
leading lady writing absolutely
beautiful inside and out I'm lucky to
know you you can write industry mayors
and it's seemingly been a love filled
spring for the young couple they
vacationed in st. Barts
and went country chic at stagecoach
Music Festival in April I know I also
was there
Taylor instagrammed his last snap with
Billy in May calling her his woman crush
Wednesday
[Music]
you